This would be the keystrokes to enter this third expression, and these would be
the keystrokes to enter this last expression. We can start entering this
expression by typing in a fraction bar, that's the forward slash. It'll create
a spot for a numerator and a denominator. After we type in the numerator, we
want to hit the right arrow key twice to move the cursor from the exponent
position down to the denominator. Then, we enter in our denominator using what
we know about the square root. After we enter this under this underneath our
radical, our cursor will appear here and we need to hit our right arrow key
twice to move back to the main line. Then, we just type in negative 4. For this
last expression, we just want to be careful with the parentheses. If we start
with an open parenthesis, another one is automatically created on the other
side. So, notice that when I get to the 5, I don't need to type in another
parenthesis, I just the right arrow key and the carrot key and a 2 for the
exponent. If you got all of these correct, you're really becoming a Math Quill
pro.